Pour les jeunes fans de dinosaures
Ces films offrent un moyen de voir
leurs rêves se réaliser.
Coupez
Génial !
La saga Jurassic est captivante, pleine de suspense.
Voici un nouveau chapitre.
En matière de dinosaures et d'invention,
on va encore plus loin.
On fait littéralement exploser l'île.
C'est la chose la plus flippante que j'ai jamais faite.
Pour ce film, on a un nouveau réalisateur, Juan Antonio Bayona.
J'adore jouer avec le suspense.
J'aime la tension
et j'adore mettre le public en immersion totale.
Il a du génie quand il s'agit de faire peur aux gens.
C'est le T-rex
Attends !
Ce n'est pas le T-rex
Attention
Les dinos disjonctent et tuent tout le monde.
Allons-y !
On voulait trouver un équilibre entre les personnages.
Ceux qu'on connaît déjà et les nouveaux.
Jeff Goldblum : je vais pas mentir, il est incroyable.
Me voilà en train de parler de dinosaures à nouveau.
Cette fois, vous allez voir plus de dinosaures que vous n'en avez jamais vu.
Dans ce film, ce sont les dinos animatroniques.
On dirait de vrais dinosaures.
J'étais tout le temps effrayée
Le défi, quand on tourne une suite,
c'est de trouver l'équilibre entre ce que les gens attendent
et ce qui va les surprendre.
Courez !
Ce film est différent, intense, spectaculaire.
Génial.
T'as vu ce jeu d'acteur
C'est du jamais vu
Normal, c'est le Jurassic.
Ca va être génial !